سداف في منزل في مخيم المغازي منزل عائله
شحده مخيم
المغازي هذه الحطره الكبيره
التي نتجت عن
هذا وادى هذا الاستف الى تدمير المنزل
وعدد كبير من المنازل
المجاوره الاسعاف
تعال
وين عائله الشده في مخيم مخيم المغازي وسط
قطع
غزه مع شيل معي يلا يا رب بسم الله اوع يا
شباب ي ا الطريق ادو الطريق ادو الطريق اد
الطريق عمال عم لا
لا طب ماشي اسحب لغاد انت روح لغاد لا لا
يا عمو عمو تتحركيش تتحركيش تتحركيش يا عم
تتحركيش تحركي خلصي خلص ماشي يا عمو ماشي
دقيقه يا عمو دقي الشب هي على قيد الحياه
رشف اخته
ياع طواقم
الانقاض هذه
الشابه انتشرت هذه الشابه الله
اكبر طواقم الدفاع المدني الان تنتشل هذه
الشا تعال
ابو سياره الاسعاف لازال
العمل من طواقم
الانقاض على انتشال طفل مازال تحت ركام
هذا المنزل ها ها
هاح وين اتحرك اه تحرك
يرجع خليه يروح يرجع الاسعاف يا جماعه هي
شكوش
ها
تعال روح
توقم الانقاذ الان تحول انتشال شهيد تحتم
هذا المنزل الان تم انتشال هذا الشهيد من
منزل عائله شحاده في مخيم المغازي هي
شهيده شهيده يتم انتشالها الان من
قبل فرق الانقاذ
الان هؤلاء الشهداء من منزل عائله شحاده
في مخيم المغاز عدد من الشهداء تم
انتشالهم تحت ركاب هذا المنزل المست تم
انتشال خمس شهداء من تحت الانقاض وتم
انتشال تم انتشال شو اسمه اثنين على قيد
الحياه
تم تم اخراجهم تحت الانقاظ وهم الحياه
اطفال
اطفال عدد من الشهداء والمصابين كذلك عدد
من المفقودين لازال تحت ركام هذا
المنزل الذي تم استهدافه من قبل مقاتلات
الاحتلال الحربيه انت مش عارف لا تزال هنا
طواقم
الاسعاف
تعمل على وضع الشهداء داخل هذه السياره
سياره الاسعاف التابعه لجهاز الدفاع
المدني هنا l